PRIYANKA VERGADIA: One of the
biggest challenges in machine
learning is building a
system to continuously
evaluate and update your
models to reflect those changes
in the environment.
Doing this can help ensure
your project's success.
But how do you do that?
Well, that is what this
video is all about.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this video
I'll walk you through a demo of
the end-to-end MLOps workflow
using Vertex AI pipelines.
In the last episode,
I introduced
MLOps and the different
steps in the ML workflow.
Let's revisit that.
[REWIND NOISE]
First step is data
transformation,
feature engineering,
and model development.
Then comes continuous training
of the model and finding ways
to automate training
and making it
repeatable, so
your ML system can
respond to newly available data
and other triggers in your ML
models.
Then deploying those
models to make predictions.
And while the model is in
production, continuously
monitoring it so that
you can make sure
that performance is improving.
And finally, we have model
management or governance
capabilities that span
across the entire framework.
And we need traceability,
verifiability, and auditability
of every single step
of this workflow, which
happens in model management.
Now, Vertex Pipelines helps us
automate this MLOps workflow.
And it does that by
orchestrating the workflow
in a serverless manner.
It is based on containers.
And as we know, containers
are portable and scalable,
and it supports
both KFP and TFX.
Each step takes an
input and provides
an output which acts as an
input for the subsequent step.
But before we jump
into the demo,
let's see the steps
that we will take.
Now, our pipeline will create
a data set in Vertex AI.
Then we would use
this tabular data set
and apply a classification
model on it using AutoML,
and then get evaluation
metrics on that model.
And based on those
metrics, we would decide
if we want to deploy the model.
So there'll be a conditional
logic in Vertex pipelines
that will help us decide this.
And then finally,
deploy the model
to an endpoint using
Vertex predictions.
Now let's see how this works.
The first step is to
create a new notebook
instance with TensorFlow
Enterprise 2.3 without GPUs.
I've already created one here,
so I'll just get into this one.
I installed the AI platform
and the Pipeline components
package.
Then we need to
restart the kernel
and check if the packages
are correctly installed.
Then I set the project ID
and cloud storage bucket
that we will be using throughout
this pipeline, followed
by the relevant library
imports, and defining
some constants, such as
the region and pipeline
route, which is the path
where the artifacts created
by our pipeline will be written.
After this initial
setup, I first
define the custom evaluation
component in our pipeline.
This component will get
the evaluation metrics
from the trained AutoML
classification model,
parse the metrics, and render
them in Vertex Pipeline's UI,
compare the metrics
to a threshold
to determine whether the
model should be deployed.
And then before we
define the components,
let's understand its input
and output parameters.
As input, this pipeline
takes some metadata
on our cloud project--
the resulting trained model,
which we will define later,
the model's evaluation
metrics, and a threshold,
which we will define
when we run our pipeline.
In the case of this
classification model,
threshold string will be the
area under the ROC curve value
for which we should
deploy the model.
For example, if we
pass in 0.95, that
means we would only
want our pipeline
to deploy the model if
this metric is above 95%.
Our evaluation component
returns true or false,
indicating whether or
not to deploy our model.
Now step two in the process is
to add our pre-built components
of the pipeline.
First, I defined
the display name
of the pipeline, then
defined the input
parameters of our pipeline.
The rest of the pipeline uses
a few pre-built components
for interacting with
Vertex AI services.
TabularDataCreateOp creates a
tabular data set in Vertex AI,
and gives the data
set source either
in cloud storage or BigQuery.
In this pipeline we're passing
the data via BigQuery table
URL.
AutoMLTableTrainingJobRunOp.
This method kicks off an AutoML
training job for a tabular data
set.
We pass a few configuration
parameters to this component,
including the model type,
which is classification here,
some data on the
columns and how long we
would like to run training for,
and pointers to the data set.
To pass in the data
set to this component,
we are providing the output
of the previous component.
ModelDeployOp deploys the model
to an endpoint in Vertex AI.
There are additional
configuration options
available, but here, we are
providing the endpoint machine
type, project, and models
we would like to deploy.
And the model is the
output of the training
step in our pipeline.
Like I mentioned earlier,
in this pipeline,
we're making use of conditional
logic, a feature of Vertex
Pipelines that lets
you define a condition,
along with different
branches based
on the result of that condition.
In our pipeline definition, we
passed our threshold parameter.
This is the accuracy
threshold we're
using to determine whether to
deploy our model to an endpoint
or not.
To implement this, we make
use of the condition class
from Kubeflow SDK.
Remember that custom model
evaluation component I created?
That's the one
we're passing here.
If this condition is
true, the pipeline
will continue to execute
the deploy component.
Otherwise, the
pipeline will stop here
and won't deploy the model.
Now, the next step
is to compile and run
the end-to-end pipeline.
For this, we use the compile
function and pass the package
path and the pipeline to it.
And then finally,
we run the pipeline.
It will take a little
over an hour to run.
But I have one
that I ran earlier,
so let me show you that one.
Here's our pipeline.
If I toggle the Expand
Artifact button at the top,
we see details of the
different artifacts
created from our pipeline.
If I click on the
dataset artifact,
it shows the Vertex AI data
sets that were created.
I'm curious about the
custom metric component
that we created.
So if you click
on this artifact,
we see the confusion
matrix for this model.
Vertex Pipelines
also lets us track
lineage of the artifacts created
throughout our pipelines.
This can help us understand
where artifacts were created
and how they are being used
throughout our ML workflow.
If we run this pipeline
multiple times,
we may want to compare
metrics across runs.
I'm doing that here
to access run metadata
for all runs of this
pipeline and load it
into a pandas dataframe.
You've now learned how to
build, run, and get metadata
for an end-to-end
machine learning pipeline
on Vertex Pipelines.
What's next?
Well, try it out yourself.
The codelab is linked below.
And if you run into
questions, reach out
to me in the comments or
@PVergadia on Twitter.